life is always now this seems almost too
obvious to state but most people live in
a way that almost contradicts the simple
fact that life is always now they live
as if some future moment were more
important than this moment so most
people always live towards the next
moment they're always on their way
towards the next moment so if they get
very old then usually they live in the
past and they still don't live in the
present moment so we are not talking
here about making plans and on a
practical level all this is necessary
and great making clients what to do with
your life or what to do the next day but
most people are never at home in the
present moment there's always something
missing there's an inner feeling that I
need to get to the next moment where I
will find some kind of completion of
fulfillment but when they get to the
next moment another next moment appears
that they need to get to need motivation
watch your top 10 with believe Nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe in myself
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today this one from one of the best
Eckhart Tolle and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
so there's first of all the simple fact
that life is always now
so it's we can learn instead of
continuously
ignoring
the present moment we can first of all
realize the amazing fact that
your entire life
is experienced
in and as the present moment
life is never not the present moment
so it's the most precious thing we have
it's we could say it's the only thing we
have
because the future what we call the
future never actually comes nobody has
ever experienced the future because the
moment the so-called future comes we
experience it as the present moment
again the past when we talk or think
about the past we can only do that in
the present moment
so even thinking about the past and
thinking about future is ultimately
happens in the present moment
now what we when we are always
mentally projecting forward into the
next moment we miss the aliveness and
vitality
of this moment which is ultimately all
there ever is
I think it's an amazing realization that
the many many people
never actually get to a place where they
are able to accept for brief moments
where they're able to
come into a
good relationship with the present
moment it's amazing there are millions
of people on the planet who live in an
almost
antagonistic relationship with the
present moment they they don't they
don't
want to be where they are they'd rather
be somewhere else they may get engaged
in some kind of activity but they'd
rather be doing something else or they'd
rather be already at the end of this
particular activity
they may be with somebody but they don't
really want to be with them they'd
rather be somewhere else you know the
bumper sticker on some cars that says
like things like I'd rather be golfing
I'd rather be fishing
so there's this um
strange fact that
the present moment is treated by in by
people internally either as antagonistic
but I just need to get to some better
moments or as a means to an end it's
always a means to an end so when you are
engaged in an activity you're already
mentally projecting yourself to the next
moment where the activity comes to an
end or whatever you want to achieve
through the activity
so
it's like being on a journey and or
mentally projecting yourself to the
destination and not realizing that the
journey
takes let's say you're on a journey
it takes a week arriving at the
destination is a one brief moment and
there you are it takes one week to get
there but if you reduce
the value of the steps that you are
taking in this moment if you reduce that
to always only a means to an end then
your entire life becomes a means to an
end
an end that never really arrives because
when you arrive at that moment then
something else immediately pops up that
you need to reach rule number two is
challenge yourself you need the
challenge and you need to challenge
yourself if you want to create something
if you want to
bring about some change in this world
you want to make your life your
so-called life better you are looking to
achieve this or to learn this or to
acquire this that's part of being human
we don't deny that
and if you don't want to achieve
anything let's say you have no ambition
whatsoever I say oh it's all pointless
because you don't want to be you don't
want to challenge yourself
then life will challenge you even more
if you don't if you're challenging
yourself would be even to engage in
physical activity and jogging you're
challenging yourself or you're lifting
weights for your challenging the body on
a physical level
the only way you can make the body
stronger the physical body is by making
let's put I'll put it like this is a
strange way of putting it but it's true
you have to make life difficult for your
body
otherwise it doesn't get stronger
well to lift the weight is I mean if you
ask the body would you rather have a
good just relax or lift this weight
I just want to relax
I don't want to have make but don't make
my life more difficult than it needs to
be so I'll just okay you don't get
stronger without the but when you you
make life difficult for the body then
more energy is demanded and more energy
comes flowing in the energy isn't come
until you demand it there's a request or
demand for energy because there's a
there's a gap between uh what you want
and what at the moment the body doesn't
have enough energy and suddenly it comes
and then you reach a point when an
influx of energy starts then you it's no
longer perceived that the the
you make life difficult for your body
once the Energy starts flowing
the body enjoys this love energy but
before the Energy starts flowing life
was difficult for the body
and so you always you meet always the
the threshold of life gets difficult for
the body and then energy comes in and
then suddenly not even perceived as
difficult anymore and that you may
experience it every day when you start
exercising rule number three is a line
to deeper purpose when I look at you
first thing I would see is your
personality or of course the physical
body and the personality whatever makes
up your personality but if I look more
deeply and not just look but actually
sense your presence I know that beyond
your personality there's an Essence in
you that it is one with the essence in
me and one could describe it as
Consciousness itself the essence of Who
You Are
the essence of who I am is consciousness
when I recognize that Consciousness the
same Consciousness that in me this
Consciousness beyond the condition
itself
recognizes the Consciousness in you that
which is beyond your condition itself
and that recognition
is what Jesus called love
and therefore he said love thy neighbor
as thyself but that is a separate
statement it doesn't work but when you
put it together with Kingdom of Heaven
that then it reads
find the Kingdom of Heaven within you
the dimension of spaciousness
then you will recognize your neighbor
which is anybody that you are with
then you will recognize him or her as
yourself and this recognition that in
essence you are one that you are deeply
deeply connected that you share the one
Consciousness when you recognize them in
the other then you have suddenly an
outflow benevolence and Good Will and
love
not the ego love but true love towards
the which in the oldest in the New
Testament Agape spiritual love for
another human being you can sense their
very beings
so and that's the whole secret of the of
of all spirituality it's in these in the
teaching of Jesus rule number four is
stop overthinking things the ability to
think of course was a wonderful
evolutionary achievement uh it it is
associated also it's linked to the
development of language too so gradually
humans develop the ability to think and
it was a wonderful evolutionary
evolutionary advance but over the over
many many Millennia
the the thinking activity began to take
over and so most human beings these days
actually never stop thinking so what
they experience is what I call a voice
in the head
which is the internal dialogue that most
people uh experience experience
throughout the day during their waking
hours
there's this continuous inner dialogue
taking place monologue dialogue whatever
you want to call it there's a there's a
commentator in the in your mind that
interprets immediately and judges
situations and people and and things
uh it spends much more time thinking
about some other moment rather than this
one and usually it's the future
and and some people of course dwell
excessively on the past too they carry
around the burden of past in their minds
and in and in the emotional field
without knowing it without realizing
that it doesn't have to be that way
without realizing that they are allowing
the past which after all is only certain
thoughts that they carry in the head
they're allowing the past to uh to
sabotage their whole life they're
carrying such a burden of past that they
can no longer experience the present so
you either burdened by the past or
you're burdened by the future now the
question of why is very important what
what is the ultimate cause of this and
that is uh the what one could call
overthinking
thinking was a wonderful thing and still
is a wonderful thing but it has taken
over human beings it has
proliferated to such an extent that now
thinking has become almost a
uh and a parasitical entity that lives
in your in your head that won't leave
you alone
you now
most people's sense of identity most
people sense of who they are is
um bound up with their mind activity
with their thinking so they derive their
sense of self from certain stories that
they're telling themselves
in their mind and that's to do with what
happened in the past what other people
did to you things you identify with that
these are
thoughts things that belong to me these
are my things these are all thought
formations
so people identify with the voice in the
head
and the voice in the head
becomes
uh
for them impossible to to distinguish
from who they are
so they talk to themselves in that you
everybody has met people in the street
who
talks themselves out aloud and usually
people look at them say oh there's a
crazy person going
but virtually everybody does that except
that they don't do it out aloud if you
could listen into when if you look walk
around in this city if you could listen
to but what's going on in people's heads
you would realize they're all talking to
themselves a lot of chatter yes and they
are so identified with it that they they
kind of they are it the voice has taken
you over the the the the Mind activity
the conceptual mind has taken you over
and then it becomes virtually becomes
you so in that state which in spiritual
terms we call unconscious when we use
the word unconscious in in spiritual
terms it does not have the same meaning
as as it has in conventional terms
usually when we use unconscious and
conventional terms we're talking about
somebody who is just dropped off he's
unconscious when we use the word
unconscious in spiritual terms it means
it refers to somebody who is totally
identified with the stream the consent
continuous stream of thinking which is
conditioned by the past the types of
thoughts that you think the stories that
you continuously revive in your head
uh I have been conditioned by your past
and the past of the culture that you
grew up in the country you grew up in
all the things that make up your past
your personal past and the collective
parts of your
environment so a person who grew up in
let's say Saudi Arabia will not be
thinking the same kind of stories and
will not interpret the world in the same
way as somebody who grew up in Canada or
in the west but what they have in common
they are both identified with the
continuous claim of things they may be
different stories there may be a
different sense of identity but but in
both cases they are they they cannot
they cannot separate themselves from The
Voice in the head also to make sure
you're actually taking action question
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is awaken your
Consciousness I haven't gone through
physical death yet
as the
the Zen master who was asked
about
life after death
said I don't know
and they said why don't you know you're
the master
and he said yeah but I'm not a dead
monster
[Music]
but I've gone very deeply to what one
could call death to identification with
form
so in a way I have gone into that Realm
from where I can say and know that
ultimately what we see as death
is the dissolution of form that
the Eternal in US
which I know that first hand cannot be
touched by that so
what exactly happens
I would say depends on
whatever state of consciousness
you were in that was be a predominant
State of Consciousness in this lifetime
if in this lifetime
you were continuously identified with
form
your body
or the psychological form of me
that means consciousness
this expression of consciousness
was still in a somewhat dreamlike state
which is identification with form
and
you can easily extrapolate from that if
the tendency of Consciousness to
identify with form was still there which
in other words
The Awakening had not happened
this tendency will continue there will
be further identification with form and
the process will continue as the
Consciousness that is not yet fully
awake
will continue to identify with form
again
and then gradually come to a place where
Awakening happens or if
there has already been a
disidentification from form in this
lifetime
then you can extrapolate from there that
the compulsive urge to identify with
form and to seek another
form or another cycle of form
identification
this compulsion to seek further
experiences through through identifying
with form
then would either be much weaker
or be completely absent
in which case the Consciousness that you
are
is no longer bound
to
this realm and will not seek to
re-experience the realm of form
but in either case
you really
I know I can tell you that all is well
it does not really matter whether
this person
now needs further
experiences of identification in which
case this will happen
or whether he is already
free of this urge in which case
he will move on and
live in a realm that we can't even
conceive of
from where we are here I get a sense
deep within in the forms of what that is
but we don't need to talk about it here
all we know is
nothing
this is the beginning of A Course in
Miracles
which is the entire Course in Miracles
summarized in two lines
nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal exists
herein lies the peace of God
that which is real in him is beyond form
anybody can know that when you see a
dead body you realize that this is no
longer whom you knew this is not the
this is not the being that you knew this
is only a shell
so nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal ultimately exists
this is why
sages from all Traditions speak of this
realm of form is ultimately illusory It
ultimately it depends what level you
look at
the important thing is
all is well
beyond the appearance on the level of
form which is the only level where death
exists it is a transition from from one
form
into another form or from one form into
formlessness
that is what death is no more than that
nothing real dies nothing real dies
which is to say ultimately
there is no such thing as death there
only seems to be it's a transmutation of
form either form dissolves or seek some
other form some other identification
with form rule number six is find the
Kingdom of Heaven Jesus often talks
about
the kingdom of heaven interesting
expression and are there's a line which
I open the Bible the other day and I saw
the line said Jesus went from Village to
Village and from town to town and said
repent for the Kingdom of Heaven is at
hand
and the whole thing is already contained
there repent means it's Miss it's a
mistranslation repentance the original
Greek is metanoia
which means a turnaround a shift a
complete shift
so the repentance what people think of
it as apologize or something like that
yes beat yourself up I'm such a
miserable sinner that's not that's a
missing it's a misinter interpretation
of repentance started when it was
translated into Latin into latiness
penitencia which was already wrong and
now we have metanoia as repentance no a
complete reverse a complete turnaround
in other words a shift in Consciousness
now what does he mean by the Kingdom of
Heaven no Christians traditionally
believed it's something that's going to
come
that she believe they completely
overlooked when they asked Jesus when
when does the Kingdom of Heaven Come he
said
the Kingdom of Heaven does not come with
observation in another translation it
says the Kingdom of Heaven does not come
with signs to be perceived you cannot
say it's over here or it's over there
for the Kingdom of Heaven is within you
no what is that thing that's within you
where you can never say it's there or
it's there
I I re-translate Kingdom of Heaven into
modern terminology
for Kingdom I would substitute dimension
and Heaven what is heaven when you look
up into heaven you see the vast Sky the
spaciousness of the sky
he used that analogy to point to an
inner reality he is used because
language usually refers to external
things that you can see and touch
so the closest that Jesus could find in
the external world to point to Something
in the inner realm was to look at the
vast spaciousness of the sky which in
itself has no particular form but it's
amazing and he said the kingdom of
heaven then is heaven my translation is
spaciousness
inner spaciousness which is the
uncluttered Mind Consciousness without
conceptual and without thought it's
inner alert Stillness
the dimension of spaciousness find the
dimension of that's the primordial
teaching in Jesus finds that within
yourself find the Kingdom of Heaven find
the dimension of inner spaciousness
where you're able to be alert and still
completely conscious but not thinking
and that's the essence of Jesus teaching
rule number seven is learn to focus have
the main focus of your attention
in your daily life
in the present moment
the rest of your attention so that's the
the main focus here is this
the rest of your attention is
where you want to go to your whatever
task you're engaged in has a certain
purpose
the purpose is you want to finish the
task and it has achieved its purpose and
that's here
and that's in the in your peripheral the
peripheral vision of your Consciousness
that's where you want to get to
and this is what you're doing in order
to get there
and your main attention is not
where you want to get and in the
meantime you're just doing it in order
to get there you can see how that's
already creates an inner stress
I'm here but I want to be there that's a
normal way of living is
the main part of people's attention is
there but in the meantime they are here
where they don't really want to be
rather be there
as shown in famous stickers on bumper
stickers on cars which say something
like I'd rather be fishing
when I visited RAM does the spiritual
teacher who has now passed away he'll
lived on Maui
on his car I saw bumper sticker which
said
I'd rather be here now rule number eight
is think positively your inner state
does not have to be totally determined
by external conditions you're not at the
mercy any longer of external conditions
which means for example also people some
people are I mean people are very
problematic people people
so proud someone is rude to you or
somebody fails to do something that they
should do or should have done all kinds
of things that you can complain about in
people's behavior
and a lot of the complaining that one
does about other people is totally
futile it does not change them because
you you when you talk to others about
them you say well do you know what he
did and then he said and I only did that
oh my God he did that or you do it in
your head
it's all futile it does not change that
person
so
uh if somebody is rude to you like oh
it's he doesn't you're carrying yourself
or the supermarket carrying your
shopping and somebody slams a dirt or on
your face because it doesn't it's rude
for many people the triggers can trigger
a train of negative thoughts that lasts
for the next 10 15 or 20 minutes
so that means and if you're completely
identified with the stream of thinking
you don't even know you think you're now
experiencing a bad reality
you do you because you have not a
stakenness you have not taken a step
back from your thinking you have not
become aware of your thinking you are so
in your thoughts that you are totally
identified with the thoughts so the the
key then is to to uh
be able to separate your your mental
interpretation of things from the
Simplicity of the isness of the present
moment so you don't add unnecessary
suffering to situations you no longer
create unnecessary suffering for
yourself
because you realize
the unhappiness that you're experiencing
in a given situation in 90 percent of
the cases is not produced
by the situation it is produced by the
way in which your mind
tells a story about the situation rule
number nine is love truly our purpose
here beyond the personal purposes that
we have everybody has their personal
purpose the work you do or whatever it
is
there's a deeper purpose that the
personal purpose must be aligned with
and that deeper purpose is to live from
that deeper place
uh the way I interpret you know in the
English language doesn't have a word
that describes both men and women it's
the German language has Mensch which is
also used in Yiddish to the German has
managed means both man or woman for a
long time I regretted that the English
language doesn't have a word for human
you have to say human being but now I'm
happy that I have to say human being
because that describes exactly the two
Dimensions the human is the conditioned
self it's a personality your historical
person which comes from the past based
on past who you are as a person that
includes your physical body and your
psychological self I call that sometimes
your form identity there's a physical
form and there's a psychological form of
you that's the human
and then there's a being the being is
the Deeper Self that is consciousness
unconditioned and no human life is
fulfilled unless the human has at least
some access
to this Dimension within them that
really is the ultimate purpose to at
least
maybe not complete access but at least
you have glimpses of that which
transcends the self to have glimpses of
self-transcendence in your life if you
you no matter how successful you are in
this world
if you have never had even a glimpse of
self-transcendence then your life is
pretty purposeless and and it's very
unlikely that you will be a happy human
being
is is the ultimate Paradox with all of
this that it's almost impossible to hold
on to so even someone that has spent
their life uh trying to attain that
State uh that you can't a you can't you
to function as a human maybe not as a
human being but just as a human uh it
would be almost impossible to constantly
be in that state in a world that doesn't
exist in that state yes not constantly
but it is possible to uh to to to not
just have that when you are perhaps
let's say engaged in spiritual practice
or you're meditating or when you're out
in nature and it's unhappy moments out
in nature it it is our task to as much
as possible
incorporate that deeper level of
Consciousness into our daily life even
if we don't succeed all the time and
that's fine that's part of the practice
so one could say then our purpose in our
daily life beyond the personal purpose
which is also important because we need
to honor
who we are as a person to and we need to
honor our identity as a person because
no doubtedly that exists and whatever it
is that makes up your identity whether
it's mostly personal kind whether you
identify with a culture a collective
around you it could be your religion it
could whatever it might be
or the culture that you grow up in that
has its place that there's nothing wrong
with it but if that is all you know
about yourself that's very limiting so
you honor it but there's more to you
than that
and that's why the ancient Greeks said
starting from Pythagoras
500 BC
know thyself the most perhaps the most
important victim in ancient Greek
philosophy which was carved cuffed on
the walls of the Temple of Apollo at
Delphi know thyself very deep saying
know who you are in your essence
so because you have the form identity
which is a personality the fall and you
hasn't have as I call it an Essence
identity and so to know yourself as this
Essence is it called in in Indian some
in some Indian Indian spiritual
philosophy is called self-realization
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is study
the mind I am is the word
all you can say
is I am
but you don't need you don't add
anything not this or that I am
in the Old Testament
God is asked who are you
then that's perhaps the most profound
sentence in the Old Testament is I am
that I am
where God defines him her itself
as the I am as the essence identity of
all forms
and also another beautiful
sentence in the Old Testament as you
know the Old Testament is a mixed the
notice the Bible is a mixed bag of
fantastic things and other things
the
but I like to look for the jewels that
are there
another beautiful statement that points
to all this is
be still and know that I am God
now these words
are all synonymous
be refers to being
still is a state of consciousness
without thought Stillness
being and Stillness is the same thing
and no
there is a deep knowing in that in fact
it's that is because that is the source
of all
intelligence there's a deep knowing
but from the point of view of the
conceptual mind
it looks like
unknowing it looks like ignorance
because it's not knowing through
Concepts anymore it's there's a deeper
knowing and this is where what we call
wisdom arises which is very different
from intelligence the IQ kind of
intelligence
the wisdom that the world needs not more
please no
but wisdom
that yes
be still and know that I am
it is the I am of the the I am of being
God
oh here we come to a difficult word
but they're all synonymous
what is God then
I rarely talk about God because you
can't really it's so Transcendent that
whatever you say would be very limited
as you know human language and human
sword is relatively limited how can I
make statements about the ultimate
Transcendent reality
just by producing a few weird sounds
with my vocal chords
Plus
air pressure through my tongue and lips
all the vowels a i a e i o u e uh
this is what language is
okay now tell me the ultimate secrets of
God in the Transcendent Universe
it's absurd
yeah
just produce a few sounds and that
explains no however I'll carry on
talking
[Music]
all we can do is give a an analogy or
like a poetic image of both God might be
and how God relates
to who you are
and that image is
I that I prefer
is the image of in of our you know we
can only use images from our sense
perceived universe
uh if the Sun is a life-giving thing in
our universe the sun gives of itself
ceaselessly for millions and millions of
years one could almost say
eternally it's not Eternal but as far as
we are concerned it's Eternal without
the sun there would be no life no
physical life here so the son gives off
itself it emanates continuously uh the
very heat in your body ultimately comes
from the Sun so the sun if you use the
Sun as an analogy for for the the
transcendent
the Transcendent God
has no location in space or time God is
neither there or if we have to say
anything we could say God is right here
because it's Transcendent to this
dimension
so if we use this as an analogy the the
Transcendent emanates into this
Dimension something that creates
form that creates life and what It
ultimately this thing that it emanates
is consciousness at first very little at
first Consciousness appears as as Israel
throws and as minerals and stones and
then Consciousness becomes as if we're
liquid if we're using earlier water then
it becomes vegetative life then again
Consciousness gradually evolves so one
Consciousness more of it comes in then
you get animal life it's like and then
you get human life it becomes ethereal
it's a human mind
emanating from the source of all life
that is transcendent of which you cannot
say anything
into this world as the sun emanates
light
the god emanates Consciousness and this
brings about this universe and in this
universe it's a process it grows
in the transcendent
we don't know anything about that so
now the important thing is
the ray of sunlight that you come that
hits your hand you feel the warms on
your hands
uh that way it's not the sun we couldn't
say I have the sun on my hand I mean if
you got close to the Sun you would
immediately disappear
but this Ray of sunlight is still
connected to the sun in some way it is
still part of the sun we can't even say
where the sun exactly ends it doesn't
really end anywhere it doesn't have a
clearly defined surface it extends
outward
so it emanates continuously
so what the what the source of all life
emanates is consciousness
and you can sense that
in yourself
when you can sense
yourself as Consciousness the presence
then you um then you realize this the
Ripple on the surface of the ocean
has realized
that it is not only a ripple I'm mixing
analogies now
it's not only a ripple more
fundamentally the Ripple is the ocean
and suddenly the Ripple is no longer no
longer no longer fearful
because it can sense its deep
connectedness
to that which is vast and
all-encompassing
and so the Ripple suddenly
lives in a different way because it
realizes
its own Timeless essence
or the Sun the ray of sunlight could do
the same it could suddenly become aware
that it is still connected and part of
the sun it can and you can sense in
yourself
the undoubted fact that you are
conscious
but not only that
we are creating a duality here that
doesn't exist when we say that you are
conscious
the essence of who you are is
consciousness so you are consciousness
the Transcendence of thinking means the
Transcendence of the egoic Mind
it means that
you are able
to
spend part of your time
relatively free of compulsive thinking
certainly free of self-serving thinking
and destructive thinking that
continuously creates unhappiness for
yourself and the people around you
how many people lived in the compulsive
narrative in your mind that for many
people is very negative constantly
critical constantly complaining never at
ease with what is there's always
something wrong fault finding because
the ego grows through the constant
opposition
constant antagonism
never at ease
always looking for the next thing to
complain about
and its strengthens the ego itself the
it the more you complain or
offended is a new version these days
it's very popular on the internet
I'm very very offended
outrageous how dare you
huh
there are thousands or hundreds of
thousands but you go on every day they
look on this their screen waiting for
the next scene to be offended by
and the ego loves it
and for many of them it's the only way
they can inflate their ego by sitting on
the screen and sending out tweets
the Transcendent of thinking is not
and any kind of regressive movement
we're not regressing to
the state of somebody who is
whose mind is relatively undeveloped
and who does not have a problem with
egoic thinking because there's very
little going on in their minds
what used to be called
before it became Politically Incorrect
idiot
or fool
the fool was
they were always you could see a happy
fools there
they don't there's not enough thinking
to rank them unhappy so there's they are
below egoic thinking
in the medieval times every village had
at least one village idiot or fool and
they were Norm was accepted the
essential part of the community
uh
and even the Royal courts had a fool
very important figure
although that figure probably was just
pretending to be a fool and that was one
of the most sometimes very influential
position in the Royal Court
but also one of the most dangerous jobs
you could have
because you could lose your head at any
moment but only the fool was able to
tell the king or queen what was wrong by
making making it into a funny story
but the fool is more deeply connected
as we know wrong from mythology
the fool is more deeply connected with
the source still hasn't gone as far out
as a normally developed human he's more
simple he a fool for example a
relatively speaking is a simpleton
dislike The Hobbit in Lord of the Rings
the The Hobbit
The Hobbit is a simple guy
doesn't should something King complex
terms loves the simple things of Life
loves eating and enjoyment
but why the fool has to go on this
important mission that nobody else can
carry out
that's a mythological motive that's
often the case because the foolish has a
connectedness still with source
that the more developed humans don't
have
similar motive in Forrest Gump in the
movie The Food does great things this
guy Forrest Gump but he's
uh
because he's alive always supports him
if he watch the movie again he always he
saves people in the war he does heroic
things but he doesn't claim credit
because he doesn't have much of an ego
yet
and all his life gives him the next
thing and the next thing
supports him
but we don't want to go there when I say
cessation of thinking I'm not talking
about regressing to this to the stage it
is the pre-thinking stage
of humanity I'm thinking about Rising
above
pointing to the possibility of rising
above thinking
so you stop thinking
which is normally associated with
the diminishment of consciousness
and Transcendence of thinking is an
intensification of Consciousness turning
up the light this is why the term
attention and alertness those terms are
extremely important they're also used in
Zen or very frequently
the Zen teachings could be described if
you wanted to summarize then
uh is what just could you can just say
simple things like pay attention
there was one zen teacher who would
whenever they asked him a question to
explain Zen
he was became quite famous
he we would always raise his finger
please explain Zen to us
what is saying I haven't quite
understood yet
[Music]
foreign
people to attention now this attention
there's a state of attention that
sometimes people experience when they're
engaged in dangerous activity you can
climb a mountain
do you think you're do you think you're
doing much thinking when you're hanging
on this wall no you can't you have to be
absolutely present in that moment you
have transcended thinking and the
situation has forced you
is forcing you into complete presence
this highest degree of alertness
without it you slip and you're gone
and so this High degree of Learners
however has no has no tension in it in
this in the case of somebody practicing
this dangerous but yes there is physical
tension but the the state itself has no
tension in it and you do not need to
engage in a dangerous activity in order
to
enter that state we are entering it here
because even as I talk about it
foreign
I hope
well I don't really hope anything but I
I trust that
as I speak about it
is
simultaneously to listening to it you
can
verify in yourself this state of
attention which is a state of very high
alertness but there's no tension in it
it's not the alertness that sometimes
goes with fear then you go but this not
uh-huh that's really a contraction of
the entire body
it's it's not really alertness it's
so that's not it it's a very it's a
relaxed alertness
this was Yin and Yang in it
coming together
and it's it's that
if you I just also mentioned the other
day when you first look at something for
the first few seconds
a new Vista a new landscape you enter a
room
or you step out of a room into the open
or whatever it is or suddenly something
new comes into your field of into your
perceptual field in the first two or
three seconds you you don't know what it
is you have to First Take it in there's
a moment of Allah's presence and this
but usually you're only aware of the
sense perception you're not aware of the
background of the alert presence itself
but you can be aware of the alert
presence itself as you take it in
and that's the key
so you're not just alertly present
you're aware of the field of alert
presence in yourself so to speak ask
yourself
and the awareness
of it and it are the same thing
cessation of thinking
now
you can try it let's
even now I would suggest that as I'm
speaking
you may find you may not know this
yet
in the moments when I'm not speaking
like now
and now
if you're alert you're not thinking
you're just present
and now
this just an alert field of presence
so
some of you
may not be able yet to be totally free
of thinking but I believe that most
people are able to feel better they have
short gaps of north or pure awareness or
no thought just a short
and then you look around
in that moment
your whole
your personal sense of self has receded
in the moment of pure presence which is
just this
you have no memories and you have no
expectations for future yeah because you
have no thought
but you're not you haven't fallen asleep
you're very awake
in that moment you're not a person
anymore
what are you
just a field of Consciousness conscious
presence
something has
emerged from within you
and has taken place of the person
the person is still there it's just gone
receded
if the only thing you
achieve in life
is this
that you are able to
become be free of compulsive and
addictive thinking
if you're able to
almost one could say to choose
not to think when there's nothing in
particular to think about
when it can just be present
so in other words
if you can step out of thinking into
aware presence that alert space
then
that is the greatest thing you could
achieve in this lifetime that any human
could achieve in this lifetime and yet
there's nobody left to say I have
achieved it that's the problem for the
ego the ego would love to say all I have
achieved the state of of presence
so it's not an achievement I'm just
saying it's an achievement but it's not
really
because you didn't do it you got out of
the way and then it happened be grateful
for whatever
you experience of this moment is and if
you cannot be grateful
at least allow it to be
because
it already is
you might as well
now if you did this little thing it
sounds very little and it is very little
allowing your experience of this moment
to be the way it is
just this little thing would remove
oh well it's hard to put it in
percentage terms let's say 95 percent of
the suffering from your life
I don't know about the rest the five
percent we'll get to that sometime
that would already remove your gigantic
chunk of unhappiness
in whatever form
unhappiness is the most generic term one
could use the Buddha called it suffering
and so for the next six months then
that obviously is one of the practices
not to internally resist
your experience of this moment
now of course
many times
thank you
possibly you'll forget that
that's fine
the moment you realize that you forgot
it
it's there again and then you can accept
the experience of this moment as the
unhappiness that is arising in you
because you forgot
to accept your experience of this moment
and so you feel this unhappiness arising
in you and you say where does that come
from
oh
I forgot to accept my experience of this
moment
and then say you accept the unhappiness
and the weird thing with unhappiness is
when you completely accept the
unhappiness it cannot survive very long
like it cannot actually coexist
with acceptance
so the weird thing then arises that
you say something like
okay I'm unhappy that's okay I don't
mind being unhappy
foreign
what's going on
it's not supposed to happen
Leah cannot
for very long were the acceptance
even the acceptance of unhappiness not
indulging in unhappiness
but the acceptance not the acceptance of
unhappiness
it presupposes that there's an awareness
there that knows that you're unhappy
now that might sound like something
very natural but it isn't
because
the most unhappy people and they're
still millions and of course they have
reasons for being unhappy yes
the
it is not necessarily the people who
you'd think would have the the most
powerful reasons for being unhappy it's
often those who you would think won't
they
are many millions to have it worse than
they but these are more happy than those
it's often the case
it's all the unhappiness
is
something that when it's recognized as
unhappiness and accepted
something happens to it it begins to
dissolve
but the really unhappy people are so
identified with the unhappiness which is
a combination of
certain
recurring thoughts in your head a
certain narrative
that is not pleasant
whether it is about
my life whether the narrative says
my life or Dreadful thing in my life
why did it all go so wrong so wrong
wrong
and now I still have to that's it's
nothing I can do and at least I'm
all with the narratives about somebody
else
The Narrative maybe about something it
hasn't happened yet and it goes on and
on
foreign
s that are reflection of the narrative
The Narrative is thoughts
certain types of thoughts
the certain thoughts that have a certain
frequency
and and then that awakens the emotional
frequency because the body thinks
the narrative in your mind is a reality
that is the reality that you're
experiencing
so you the body reacts with an emotion
it's a simple simple example at night
you can't sleep because you're extremely
worried about what's going to happen to
you
or somebody close to you
or even the world
and
it all sounds very critical
there's a crisis in your head
not outside outside your head there's a
pillow
and there's a
blanket or even something big and fluffy
and soft
down duvet
[Music]
and there's no unhappiness there and if
you look around the bedroom also where's
the unhappiness
and it's okay it's not unhappy
you know it's all happening in here
[Music]
and then the body since that is your the
critical reality that you inhabit you
are there is a crisis in your life the
body doesn't know the difference between
what's actually happening and what's
happening in your head what's happening
in your head is
taken to be the absolute reality
and then you can experience the emotion
that goes with that kind of narrative
and so there's no awareness and when
you're trapped in that you don't even
really know that you are unhappy because
you are the unhappiness the unhappiness
has become your identity so when you
become the unhappiness you don't even
know that your own self let's use the
Buddhist term suffering
when you are in this deep suffering you
don't even know you're suffering because
the suffering is a gigantic huge chunk
part of your dead sense of self you are
a suffering entity
and as
all therapists know that
once the patient or the client or
whatever they call the people that come
to them according to their school
the
they reach a point where there's a
possibility of going beyond the
deep-seated patterns unconscious
patterns and then there's a huge
resistance very often
because the person is afraid of losing a
very important
piece of their identity and sometimes
it's the most important part of the
identity if they have lived with an
unhappy sense of self for years and
perhaps even decades
they don't want to let go and again they
don't know that consciously they they
never say I do not want to let go but if
they could say that then that means
there's already some awareness so
lack of awareness lack of presence that
is the unawakened state
that still unfortunately millions of
humans are trapped in that
but the moment you know you recognize
your inner state
that that means there's an awareness
which is there is another dimension of
Consciousness that has emerged in you
through you
a deeper dimension of Consciousness that
is not the conditioned thinking
that's what we can call it awareness we
can call it presence you can call it
the unconditioned consciousness
and
then the beginning of Freedom around the
possibility of Freedom arises and it's
from there that you recognize your inner
states as they arise from there that you
recognize
your unhappiness and say oh you can like
you can feel the unhappiness
but the more you become aware of
suffering on happiness
in you you're no longer feeding it with
your thoughts
as long as you're not aware you're
feeling it there's a vicious circle
you're feeding it with your thoughts
with your narrative and you're trapped
in the Vicious Circle your narrative
creates more unhappiness the unhappiness
creates more thought
and you're trapped in that
so for the next six months and and
hopefully Beyond because it's a much
more pleasant way to live
you make it your practice to be aware of
your inner states and meaning
no matter what situation arises in your
life whether it's the little things big
things
difficult situations difficult people
challenges problems
because the next six months are not
going to be free of challenges and
problems
so whatever it is
realize that the primary factor
in any situation
is your inner state
because that determines how you respond
so no matter what it is your primary
responsibility is
to be aware of what goes on inside you
and
that means whatever arises in your life
is actually to be used in your practice
so that you do not
become
dependent on what's going on
externally in your life so your inner
State gradually is no longer
determined perhaps still a little bit
yes
but not completely determined by our
events people situations and so on in
our freedom arises that's Awakening
adversity can
either it can strengthen the ego
or it can gradually or in some cases
suddenly
dissolve the ego or at least diminish it
so it can go either way
and I must agree with you I don't know
whether you literally said it
in perhaps still in the majority of
cases
it strengthens the ego because nobody
knows people don't know
it was the opportunity that every
adversity represents so why does it
happen how does it strengthen the ego
you can see it sometimes with people who
are sick
of people who are disabled to us let's
say I've met disabled people people with
physical disabilities for example
and in some cases
they are very they're really angry with
the world and bitter because look at
what happened to me they say why do I
can't move anymore I've been Afflicted
with this what have I done
to deserve this and these are
questions that are still there the
justifiable questions the the question
what what have I done to deserve why has
the world or whatever they say go to the
world the universe or whoever they've
done this to me while and then they
become
bitter and angry and the ego becomes
more and more rigid and hardened and uh
[Music]
and so that is one way it could go and
then I have met people with disabilities
who through their disability
at some point whether through a
spiritual teaching and in some cases
never come into contact with any
spiritual teaching it just happened that
at some moment they realized intuitively
that all the suffering
was generated this whole resistance and
then the resistance to the is-ness of
their life this moment
they were able to let go because perhaps
the suffering was getting too much
something happened
clicked inside
or even if it didn't happen completely
they were able to have moments of
uh inner peace
an inner peace that is not caused by an
external condition
an inner peace that seems to be in
control contradiction to an external
condition so that they would survive How
could a person who is suffering this
feels so peaceful and so
um
also that applies to people who are
approaching the end of their lifespan
because they have some illness and they
have been to the doctor and the doctor
says you have six months or one year
and
so and suddenly
something Inland opens up and all that
remains is
that the person already dies there's no
more future and All That Remains is the
present moment and the the aware space
so I've had the privilege of working
with when I was still seeing individuals
whether two or three people to whom that
happened
and they became luminous beings in the
last few weeks or months of their lives
and became just
there was no there wasn't I couldn't see
there was any person left there was only
a space of conscious presence left
just wonderful as at least they had just
come into this world
so they came and then they came to me
and then still asking questions very
profound questions wanting to understand
what happened and it was beautiful
so this can happen it can happen
collectively to people who have
you go through Warfare and in countries
or become refugees they lose everything
and again it can go either way
uh whenever there's any great loss in
your life that again an opportunity
opens up
if if you resist and you regret you
resist the resistance of origin the
origin of their existence is a narrative
that forms in your mind
uh that says something about the
situation and about your life and about
other people uh so the narrative forms
in your mind and the narrative is an
unhappy one
and then there's continuous resistance
and non-alignment with the illness of
the present moment now one could ask
well how could somebody who is lost
who's lost their home perhaps even lost
love loved ones
and then they don't know where to go
how could this person be in a state of
alignment with the present moment isn't
that how can how can somebody accept the
unacceptable
except that which in conventional terms
would be regarded as unacceptable how is
that how is that possible
but that's precisely it
if you can accept the unacceptable that
is the sudden the opening and then you
realize
the unacceptable is actually not
unacceptable it is acceptable
and the I was homeless was a period in
my life with not knowing what what to
live on the network
next day or the next week and
I had already gone into a state of
acceptance so it was a very pleasant
experience but potentially would have
been extremely unpleasant
so not having a home was for me already
something that wasn't not experienced as
something bad but I knew I had to take
some action
eventually to to get a home and so
gradually
something happens I don't want to talk
too much about that
I also mentioned in the
the new ass I believe
um when I was at University there was
the
Stephen Hawkins the physicist who was
confined to a wheelchair who passed away
a few couple of years ago on there it
was
he would always he wasn't famous at that
time only famous locally in the
University we would always be in the
same dining room having lunch but not
the same table I never
we met him was introduced as well
observed him many times did he better
neighboring table
and I said and then I
the one moment when I hold out opened
the door for him he was coming through
on his wheelchair
and I looked into his eyes and I could
see there was no unhappiness
[Music]
any video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
me check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there model
success success excludes the famous
expression and it's true people have
already figured out the thing that you
are struggling to figure out and the
more you are stuck trying to come up
with every idea yourself the harder
you're making it on yourself and this is
one of